[Music]
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
[Music]
oh look we're really sorry Spooner some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it you ratted
us out hey don't use that word that way
I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
yeah
this is insane Turtle Mutant karate
teams I want to know everything about
you our dad is definitely not a giant
rat that makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
she's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
talk I dream about fighting every night
you guys you've got rage it's not a
problem
[Music]